C'est très excitant
comme opération qui sera lancée
en octobre.
René Doyon, directeur
de l'Institut de recherche sur
les exoplanètes à l'Université
de Montréal, bonsoir.
Est-ce que c'est ce monstre qui
va nous donner la réponse que
l'on cherche depuis toujours?
Est-ce qu'il y a de la vie sur
d'autres planètes?
- Si on a la réponse, on va
faire des pas importants pour
avoir la réponse. Olivia l'a
bien souligné, on connaît
maintenant plus de 4000
exoplanète il en a une poignée
qui pourrait être Daleman
potentiellement habitée. La clé
pour le savoir, c'est de
détecter l'atmosphère. On le
fait déjà avec un télescope
spatial mais il n'a pas la
puissance suffisante pour le
faire correctement. Celui-ci
pourra le faire. L'instrument
canadien que nous avons conçu
spécialement pour faire
justement cela, non seulement
détecter l'atmosphère de ces
planètes mais aussi d'en
déterminer la Comp position
chimique. Est-ce qu'il y a de
l'eau, du CO2, du méthane qui
sont les éléments importants
pour que la vie y apparaisse?
- Il sera en orbite à quel
endroit?
- 1,5 millions de kilomètres au-
dessus de la terre.
La raison pour laquelle on
l'envoie aussi loin, c'est qu'on
veut le mettre constamment dans
l'ombre du soleil. Le télescope
détecter la lumière infrarouge.
- 1,5 millions de kilomètres et
il va tourner autour de la terre
néanmoins?
- Il va suivre la terre dans son
orbite autour du soleil. Il sera
constamment dans l'ombre du
soleil grâce à son écran solaire
qui est de la taille d'un
terrain de tennis. Comme cela,
et d'ailleurs, il y a le panneau
solaire et toutes les antennes
de communication pour envoyer
des données sur. Il aura trois
antennes sont à constamment qui
pourront prendre ces données.
- Il va pointer, parce que dans
la Voie lactée, notre galaxie,
il y a entre 100 et 400
milliards de soleils. Il va
pointer vers où? Est-ce qu'on a
déjà déterminé quelle étoile
nous intéressait et quelle
planète nous intéresse autour de
ces étoiles?
- Absolument. On l'a vu, le plan
d'observation est alloué pour la
première année. Il va faire une
panoplie d'observations d'abord
dans notre propre galaxie.
D'abord des étoiles plus près et
aux confins de l'univers, on va
observer les toutes premières
galaxies qui se sont alignées,
il y a quelques centaines de
millions d'années, après le
début de Lune d'hiver.
On a encore sondé cette région.
Il a été conçu vraiment pour
cela au tout début il y a 20
ans, pour voir le plus grand feu
d'artifice cosmique qui a eu
jamais eu lieu dans l'univers.
- Mais restons dans notre
galaxie pour l'instant. Dans
notre galaxie, je le disais, il
y a un nombre incalculable
d'étoiles et de soleils et de
planètes qui tournent autour de
ses soleils. On a déjà la liste.
Sur cette liste, est-ce que vous
vous dîtes, sont-elles
exoplanète, et devrait peut-être
avoir de la vie? On a déjà une
liste de sélectionner?
- Absolument. On la dit dans le
reportage, il y a un système
planétaire vraiment unique,
c'est la vedette. C'est un
système planétaire qui est une
étoile à peine plus grosse que
Jupiter autour de laquelle il y
a cette planète qui tourne
autour. Ils ont à peu près la
taille de la terre dont trois
qui sont dans la zone habitable,
ni trop loin ni tout près de
l'étoile pour qu'on puisse
espérer trouver de l'eau
liquide.
Comme l'a dit Olivia, on ne sait
pas encore si ces planètes ont
une atmosphère et la seule façon
de le savoir, c'est avec les
instruments à bord du satellite
est-ce qu'il y a du temps
d'observation et aussi dans le
cadre de la contribution
canadienne, nous aurons du temps
garanti, dont la moitié sera
dédiée pour étudier ce système
planétaire.
- On va chercher Célia de la vie
sur les exoplanète et vous
l'avez dit, on va aussi regarder
très loin, donc dans le passé de
l'univers et on va regarder les
autres galaxies plus loin. Est-
ce qu'on va se rendre aussi loin
qu'on n'était jamais allé?
- Tout à fait. L'instrument, le
télescope qui a permis d'aller
aussi loin, c'est obole, dans
l'espace. Mais malheureusement,
il a une limite parce qu'il
observe surtout dans le domaine
visible. Les galaxies très
lointaines émettent de la
lumière dans le domaine
infrarouge. Ce n'est pas un
hasard si ce nouveau télescope a
été conçu pour cela. On doit
absolument observer ses galaxies
dans l'infrarouge. On parle de
galaxies qui se sont formées
peut-être il y a 300 millions
d'années après le big-bang.
- Jusqu'où on peut aller?
- C'est la limite. Ça prendrait
d'autres instruments différents
pour la suite. Mais pour ce qui
est d'étudier les tous débuts de
l'univers, on parle de la
formation des premières
galaxies.
- Mais la forme de l'univers,
est-ce qu'on va en savoir
davantage? Est-ce qu'on va
arriver à cette réponse? Est-ce
qu'on va comprendre davantage
l'univers et au-delà?
- Plus ou moins. Il y a d'autres
missions davantage dédiées à
cette question spécifique.
James Webb est un télescope
d'usage général, on parle des
galaxies lointaines, mais c'est
beaucoup plus que cela qu'il va
faire. C'est un programme,
il y a plus de 4000 chercheurs
dans le monde qui sont impliqués
dans les programmes
d'observations qui ont lieu dans
la première année.
- Très bien. On va en reparler à
l'automne parce que tout cela
sera lancé le 31 octobre
prochain. On va en reparler
parce que l'élément canadien et
montréalais est important.
- Tout à fait. C'est
l'instrument canadien qui a été
conçu en grande partie à
l'université de Montréal. Ce
sont deux caméras en hune. Il y
a une caméra critique pour le
télescope, la caméra de guidage.
Chaque fois que qu'on va pointer
un corps céleste, ce n'est pas
parfait. Il y a des vibrations.
Le télescope vibre. Les images
sont embrouillées. Il y a
d'abord un petit miroir qu'on
peut basculer et la caméra
canadienne pourra détecter un
mouvement de télescope et ce
mouvement, il est tellement
précis qu'il est l'équivalent de